i'm going to read out for you guys
everyone knows that walking to a party
beside a supermodel is a terrible idea
but paulina poriskova is inviting me to
do just that she has a point to prove
you have to come with me she insists
nobody believes me until they see it my
girlfriends thought i was joking at
first now they've all witnessed i am now
completely invisible paul ryskovis
explains i walk into a party i try to
flirt with guys and they just walk away
from me to pursue someone 20 years
younger
i'm very single i'm dressed up i've made
an effort but nothing worked the only
way to gain visibility in our society is
to look younger if you look young your
age nobody will listen to you and if you
want to be heard you can't look your age
do i feel sexier
oh my god yes but what am i not but am i
not anymore it's feminine i'm not
fluttery vulnerable creature i'm an
active participant an instigator i like
to have fun i know what i'm doing
i wish there were more women who dared
to age we are a society we're set up for
women to look like little girls that
shouldn't be okay with us we need
we need a collective movement to fight
ageism no but it requires vending of the
sisterhood which just hasn't no no
girlfriend no no i'mma stop you right
there no you were a model
you you were a model
you were twice in sports illustrated you
were a model
baby girl you are the one that
contributed to that
okay you were once that and you got that
job because of that stop stop
stop you got me [ __ ] up stop don't
don't do it no now that you're not in
that no more you want to do a movement
no baby girl that's not what we're going
to do we're not going to do that it's
like whenever i heard kim kardashian the
other day i don't mind kim kim's doing
great yeah do your thing girlfriend but
she's talking like oh my god the
pressure of the looks and you know it's
so much pressure in the industry to look
all them [ __ ] out there trying to
look like you kim
all the [ __ ] trying to look like you
it's really so hard with the standards
you're the standard
that's you
you're the standard it's like whenever
french people they come to montreal and
they be here they're like
you're you're
you're not stuck in traffic your traffic
you contributed from that don't know kim
kim you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
want and you're great live your life you
and uh skeet davidson whatever his name
is skeets pete yeet uh neat uh feet beat
uh [ __ ] whatever all of that do you boo
boo but telling me that oh my god just
no
it's the same thing for her
you were you you you ate you ate that's
it you ate with that yeah you ate with
that standard you ate with all of that
you were young and fresh and you were
that thing and you were that one don't
baby don't yeah you know you miss it
that's what it is it's like that de
chapelle joke where white women are out
here crying about
they're crying crying about the
patriarchy and oppression all this stuff
it's like [ __ ] you were part of the
heist that's bill burr you just didn't
like your cut oh there you go you you
know that was that was that was dave
chappelle yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like mid you were part of the house
part of the house you just didn't like
your cuts yes you were part of that
oppression stop you were the one putting
out them false accu
on black dude don't play no don't play
no okay no where are you at where you at
whenever you got caught with a with
together now that i'm old and we got to
fight ageism or maybe you at your age
are not supposed to be what dudes are
looking for
the same way i don't get mad at young
women going after old
because they like the stability they
like the cars they like the place they
have to live they prefer older men i'm
not gonna get dude mad at dudes who like
younger women you feel invisible that's
your problem you probably didn't feel
invisible when you were in your 20s but
guess what the average 20 year old male
is invisible
yes
yes and when you were when you were
twice on the sports illustrated and you
had all the mansion then 20 years
we're not the ones that you were eating
with the invisible 20 words were the
ones who were jerking off to your
magazines stop okay stop don't play
that's the only way they could get
access so you can miss fat it's sad to
say
but
your turn is past your turn has passed
because you ate boo boo it's
thanksgiving you ate and you just got
your your piece of humble pie no i'm
sorry no
no you could you could you could beyonce
that [ __ ] to the left of the left
girlfriend i'm not having that i saw her
pictures okay let me tell you something
this girl does not have an issue
attracting men the problem she has is
she doesn't attract the man that she
thinks she deserves yeah that's her
issue yeah because i'll be sure you got
her 1840 the way she looks dudes would
still bang her the problem is she not
getting the results she wanted so now
she's blaming the society rather than
her own choices nope changing her party
at some point i remember
i'm a club head you understand what i'm
saying i've been going to clubs since i
was 15 years old all right i've been
going young at some point in my life i
was going to clubs and i was getting
annoyed at the people around me
everybody around me could not be the
problem i was the one that was too old
outside the club i had to change club if
that party you're invisible boo boo
honey chicken cherry chow honey bunny
bunch uh boo boo [ __ ] you have to
change party okay and when does it end
when does it should i should should we
go into [ __ ] nursing homes i'd be
like we need to make these [ __ ]
geriatric
you know what i mean oh yeah the [ __ ]
in the wheelchair you can't move their
neck and think we need to make them no
listen
listen wheelchair is a new sexy listen
i'm i'm so sick and tired of women
having the craziest dating standards
certain level of income certain height
certain all this other stuff got to be
bigger than me whatever it might be and
then dudes say we not to older women
all of a sudden them shrink donkey
noises come out no
you're not gonna get no sympathy for me
i'm sorry
not in that regards now look i will say
aging is a tough thing for some folks
because they want to live like at 40
like they still 20. they want to have
the same reaction from people at 50 like
they're 30. that's not going to happen
aging is kind of like going through the
seasons
you don't get to live in your summer for
the rest of your life
you got to go through
a fall and [ __ ] winter is coming yeah
the white walkers the undead they all
coming for you
so you got to accept a certain reality
about life and that's not true just for
you it's true for us right you start in
summer women start in summer we start in
winter no no we started
late winter this spring it takes a
little bit more day yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the thing
what i'm saying it's like it's a reverse
first because i really hear this
rhetoric but women say it's not fair
because men don't have like a uh a
biological clock yeah a clock or you
don't have like a due date it's not that
it's that we're not cool
in our 20s when we're young we're not
there we're not there we ain't got that
monies if we got the faith if you ain't
got the faith and you're young
then that's most of us you better have
some money you better have some money
it's not everybody that got rich rich
rich parents so we struggle but you you
get it right away when you go clubbing
you go in right away you get in for free
you you you because you're hot any girls
there us we're waiting in line listen i
i say it every day
be an average girl on tinder be an
average dude on tinder
night of the day not the same game but i
don't even like yeah you have even the
luxury of being picky average girls is
tinder is a booster for you yeah and for
average guys oh it's a reality check but
shout out to all my ugly women because i
know you guys got a terrible like like
like the really ugly ones like you know
what i mean you guys are extra invisible
so you know i got a little sympathy for
you but that's not hurt you still
[ __ ]
who the ugly ones ugly ugly guy
even ugly girl and ugly ugly guy the
name is different i'm gonna give you i'm
gonna keep a stack with you i'm gonna
keep it stacked with you i would rather
be a really ugly guy that'd be a really
ugly girl
and i'll die on that one why because
dudes can do things to increase their
value that have nothing to do with their
looks
you can get in really good shape fair
you could get some money fair you can
turn it around
you an ugly girl you got me you gonna be
born an ugly girl and you're gonna die
an ugly girl
true so i gotta show them a little bit
of courtesy because i'm like you
struggling fair not the same struggle
but you're struggling
fair but it's a little girl so i mean
i'm still better it's still better i
think it's still better there's still
going to be more virgin guys than girls
yeah because they're ugly but i want
mobility i want upward mobility fair you
get what i'm saying
i want to be able to climb the ranks
yeah
i'm not trying to stay in poverty zone
for the rest of my life
being at the top of the poverty zone is
not the best place to be i'd rather have
an opportunity to get with the rich
[ __ ] you feel me at the bottom yeah
yeah
i can go straight to the top if you get
enough money you don't think elon musk
looks sexy to every girl
yeah
there you go
this dude's autistic and everything he
barely
flamethrowers rocket science just
a bit's like what are these like
billions of dollars like yeah
is that how much money yeah is that your
richest man in the world
what bridge are we dismantling
that's different
i just don't feel sorry you know it's
like that's jeff you have to understand
when your peak is when you have the most
quote-unquote market value maybe you
don't want to start getting married at
that point that's fine but don't be mad
because you enjoyed your summer and
[ __ ]
all of a sudden you didn't realize it
but winter showed up it's like no put on
your raincoat
wait no put on your winter coat all of a
sudden you don't look sexy anymore trust
me i live in a cold place nobody looks
sexy in winter everybody looks like the
michelin man like you got tires for a
body that's it
but that's what the season entails
it's your time
so
um i just i i'm just dying of these
people like what did they expect at 80
years old you still won't be desirable
it's like [ __ ] if you're not gonna
settle down then then
you you made your bed you had your fun
you know what i'm saying like
what i ate am i supposed to oh we gotta
fight ageism while his arm is hanging
off the body like come on bro you ate
you ate with that yeah
yeah you ate now you got diarrhea
talking about oh you don't know
who told you to overeat
no who told you to overeat
this girl out here stuffing her face
with chocolate cake enjoying every sweet
under the sun surprised when she got
diabetes at 40. uh who told you to do
that was it me i didn't sneak no sugar
in your food soggy
you was that dairy queen every day that
was you
was it not i'm i wasn't there yeah and
now she talked about well we need to
change the food industries like don't
eat dairy don't eat
you got him [ __ ] up